Can you back, but when I get fed down
this way, I shut up.
That's weird. You don't even know what direction, right?
What is the correct direction front to back? I don't get,
what are you angry about? Sassy.
All of a sudden ask us about
[inaudible] those kinds of dirty questions.
We're just talking about beautiful things. You know, you know,
the one memory that I have, I feel bad about me. You about you and I.
What is that one time you picked me up from camp.
Yeah. Oh my God.
Now he trying to hug and he pushed me pushing me away. Which,
so you dropped him off. What happened was I,
so I went to a summer camp where they picked us up in a yellow boss.
Took us into the forest for a month and came back. Yeah, yeah. Then I say,
hi, all the kids are like getting off of the boss.
And I was on the bus. I remember thinking, and people were,
kids were hugging their parents,
but some cool kids weren't they were like, Hey mom.
Right. And getting in the car. And that's what I wanted to do.
But my mom wanted to do cry, mild kisses and the whole thing.
It's why I pushed her. And when I did that, it broke.
I could see it breaking her heart, you know?
Oh, shut up my tongue. Yeah. Because
I always, when I go to a screw out Stephens,
I always put on makeups. So look better. Oh,
you did that for us because I don't want you to push me like that.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'll never, I never,
I never thought about it. That's why I brought it up. I feel bad.
I'm never going to do that again. How he trying to help him? I appreciate that.
And then just, you know, you dealing with just the whole, I mean,
just the whole life. I know the whole thing. The whole thing is, um,
it's beautiful though. Isn't it beautiful life.
Oh, some good.
Some bad. But like when I look at, you know, like my, uh,
shoots are not your past still bad.
I thought I grew up very poor.
But when I look at all over the world, I wasn't that bad,
you know? And I thought I'm better because of my friend, the corny peanuts.
I'm so small and well, your friends called you peanut. It was the nickname,
peanut peanut, because we're small, small or less in the class.
I'm kind of bad with Korean.
No, I'm regular.